Ah, ah,
yeah,
Gosuke-kun
, please cooperate for the experiment.
Imaginary Inukai Kosuke, a man who lives
in unwavering love.
I don't like places close to the
horns. It's nice to have them on my feet. I feel like it's too sticky.
I didn't feel anything-I don't have
Hida with a big smile-It's a
long time-It's about 30 seconds-I'm almost
laughing at my eyes.
I didn't have any friends of the same sex. I don't
know if it's because of this kind of personality.
I don't think
I'm gonna smoke line Peio I just want to suck and crush
my sister I also wanted a sister who caught
kanade chan
[music]
I've been waiting for this
ah ah ah
[music]
throw it for 30 seconds
Do you really want to kiss us with the natural
feeling of kissing? Necessary experiment turn unavoidable Hand wipe Ose
Otaka is a misa.